a woman who has decided to go into war  zones and take pictures you're a bit  crazy to want to do that I think now  you're too crazy to stop we please tell  everybody to stop leaving me messages  I'm not calling anybody back not to me  me they put a rifle to the back of marks  head and blew his brains out it cannot  be alone right now get on that flight  tomorrow come back here okay thanks bye  how old it is opened I ran into  something I just want pain medication I  know you I took your photograph with  your brother in Libya I know you but I  want to help you you will help me no  more time  why did he hit you I advise you to be  more careful about the company you  choose stop going in my room  you've got this story that's what we  want to be there when it breaks when did  the story break what did they do  you